What could be more American than the person who sees something they've never done before, dreams they could do it, goes after that dream? Well, let's begin today with a woman who dreams of directing a play in the small town where she lives, a college town somewhere below the Mason-Dixon line in the hills of Appalachia, a town which will remain, for our purposes today, unnamed.
有什么比一个从未做过某事的人，梦想着自己能做到，然后去追求这个梦想的人更像美国人的呢？嗯，今天我们从一位女士说起，她梦想在自己居住的小镇导演一出戏，那是一个位于梅森-迪克森线以南、阿巴拉契亚山脉中的大学城，为了我们今天的目的，这个小镇将保持匿名。
I don't think she'd ever directed. And she claimed to have acted. And it was never really quite clear just what her credentials were. But she had managed to convince the local theater department of this college that she should direct a production of Peter Pan.
我想她从未导过戏。她声称自己演过戏。对于她到底有什么资历，从来没有真正弄清楚过。但她设法说服了这所大学当地的戏剧系，让她导演一出《彼得·潘》。
When he was in the 10th grade in 1973, Jack Hitt saw her production. And like everybody else in town, he heard about it for weeks beforehand.
1973年，杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）上十年级时看了她的演出。和镇上的其他人一样，他在演出前几周就听说了这件事。
Slowly but surely, you began to hear sort of rumors about this production. For example, I know that they had spent a lot of money renting these flying apparatuses out of New York. And apparently, there's, like, one company and a handful of these apparatuses. So to get them was a major coup.
慢慢地，肯定地，你开始听到关于这出戏的流言蜚语。例如，我知道他们花了很多钱从纽约租借这些飞行设备。显然，好像只有一家公司有少量的这种设备。所以能得到它们是一项重大举措。
This is a story not just of a mediocre play or a terrible play. When it comes right down to it, it's not even a story about a play. This is a story about a fiasco and about what makes a fiasco. And one ingredient of many fiascoes is that great, massive, heart-wrenching chaos and failure are more likely to occur when great ambition has come into play, when plans are big, expectations great, hopes at their highest.
这不仅是一个关于平庸之作或糟糕之作的故事。归根结底，这甚至不是关于一出戏的故事。这是一个关于惨败的故事，以及什么是惨败的故事。许多惨败的一个组成部分是，当巨大的野心发挥作用时，当计划宏大、期望很高、希望达到顶峰时，巨大的、毁灭性的、令人心碎的混乱和失败就越有可能发生。
And what you have to understand is that everybody in this sort of community understood that there was certainly a sort of air of everyone reaching beyond their own grasp. Every actor was in a role that was just a little too big for them, every aspect of the set and the crew.
你需要理解的是，这个社区里的每个人都知道，有一种每个人都在超越自己能力范围的气氛。每个演员的角色对他们来说都稍微大了一点，舞台和剧组的每一个方面也是如此。
And rumors had cooked around. There was this huge crew. There were lots of things being painted.
谣言四起。有一个庞大的剧组。有很多东西在被喷漆。
See, but this, in fact, is one of the criteria for greatness, that everyone is just about to reach just beyond their grasp, because that is when greatness can occur.
你看，但事实上，这是伟大的标准之一，每个人都即将达到他们能力范围之外，因为那是伟大可能发生的时候。
That's right. That's right. And maybe greatness could have occurred.
没错。没错。也许伟大本可以发生。
Well, today on our program, what happens when greatness does not occur. What happens, in fact, when fumble leads to error leads to mishap, and before you know it, you have left the realm of ordinary mistake and chaos, and you have entered into the more ethereal, specialized realm of fiasco. Today's show, Fiascoes, a philosophical inquiry-- perhaps the first ever, as far as we know-- into what makes a fiasco, what takes our ordinary lives the extra distance into fiasco.
好了，今天在我们的节目中，当伟大没有发生时会发生什么。事实上，当失误导致错误导致事故，在不知不觉中，你就离开了普通错误和混乱的领域，进入了更空灵、更专业的惨败领域。今天的节目《惨败》，是一次哲学探究——据我们所知，也许是史上第一次——关于是什么造就了惨败，是什么让我们普通的生活在通往惨败的道路上多走了一段距离。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program in four acts. Act One, Opening Night. Act Two, a fiasco involving a village, marauding Visigoths, a 1,9000-pound brass cauldron, and some oil. Don't even ask. Act Three, Squirrel Cop, in which a bushy-tailed visitor threatens to take down two police officers, a married couple, a couch, and a house. Act Four, Fiascoes as a Force for Good in this World.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，首演之夜。第二幕，一场涉及村庄、掠夺成性的西哥特人、1900磅重的黄铜大锅和一些油的惨败。别问了。第三幕，松鼠警察，一只长着毛茸茸尾巴的访客威胁要打倒两名警官、一对已婚夫妇、一张沙发和一栋房子。第四幕，惨败作为这个世界的一种向善力量。
There is much, much to learn about fiascoes in this hour. Stay with us.
在这一个小时里，关于惨败有很多很多可以学习的。请和我们在一起。
We begin our show with this true fable of Peter Pan in Act One, Opening Night.
我们以第一幕《首演之夜》中关于《彼得·潘》的真实寓言开始我们的节目。
Opening night comes, and, well, almost everybody in the area, in the 10-mile radius of this theater, knows somebody in this production. So the place is pretty much packed. And I don't know if you remember the opening moment of Peter Pan, but it's the three little kids sleeping in their bed. And Peter Pan comes flying in the window.
首演之夜到了，嗯，在这个剧院方圆10英里内的几乎每个人都认识这个剧组里的某个人。所以这里几乎挤满了人。我不知道你是否记得《彼得·潘》的开场，是三个孩子睡在床上。然后彼得·潘飞进窗户。
And in this particular production, there's a big bed with all the three kids in it. And off to the left, I remember, is a big, huge wardrobe. And there's a large window there, and a little bureau. And Peter Pan comes in and has the little speech where he says, "Anybody can fly. Why, with just a little magic dust, one can fly." And Peter Pan sprinkles this magic dust in the air.
在这部特定的作品中，有一张大床，三个孩子都在里面。我记得在左边是一个大大的衣柜。那里有一扇大窗户，还有一个小梳妆台。彼得·潘进来说了那段小演讲，他说：“任何人都可以飞。嘿，只要一点魔法粉，人就可以飞。”然后彼得·潘向空中撒了这些魔法粉。
And sure enough, the kids suddenly just lurch into the air. And it becomes clear right away that the people that they've hired to run these flying apparatuses really aren't quite clear on how they actually work. So instead of the kids sailing gracefully to and fro, they hang in the air like puppets, just dangling there and getting jerked up an inch or two or back and forth.
果然，孩子们突然晃进了空中。很明显，他们雇来操作这些飞行设备的人真的不清楚它们到底是怎么工作的。所以，孩子们并没有优雅地来回飘动，而是像木偶一样悬在半空中，就在那里摇晃，被猛拉一两英寸或来回摆动。
And then sometimes they're just stationary?
然后有时他们只是静止不动的？
Yeah. Just hanging there like a spider.
是的。就像蜘蛛一样悬在那里。
And then several of them start to circumscribe these circles in the air, where it's clear that the people running the machines have just set them off on these oval courses that spiral farther and farther out. And if you're sitting in the audience, there was clearly a sense of fear on the faces of these people.
然后他们中的几个人开始在空中划这些圆圈，很明显，操作机器的人只是把他们设置在这些椭圆形轨道上，螺旋形地越转越远。如果你坐在观众席上，可以清楚地看到这些人的脸上充满了恐惧。
Of the actors?
演员们的？
The actors. The actors actually-- you could sense their lack of confidence, shall we say, in the people running the machines in the back.
演员们。演员们实际上——你可以感觉到他们缺乏信心，我们这么说吧，是对后台操作机器的人的缺乏信心。
Wait, wait. And the audience reaction to this point is just-- are they laughing?
等等，等等。观众到这一点的反应只是——他们在笑吗？
No one is laughing. This is one of the great things about audiences, especially in a live theater production, is that they're very forgiving. They want the show to work. And so everyone is gripping their chair a little tightly. We feel for them. They're up there. They're embarrassing themselves for us.
没有人笑。这是观众的伟大之处之一，尤其是在现场戏剧制作中，他们非常宽容。他们希望演出成功。所以每个人都把椅子抓得紧紧的。我们为他们感到难过。他们在那里。他们正在为我们让自己出丑。
We identify with them. We become them.
我们认同他们。我们变成了他们。
And so the audience, I think, was very forgiving and very understanding of this moment. But there was one moment in this first opening scene that put the audience on notice. And that's when, as the kids are jerking up and down and swinging back and forth and going around in these ovals, at one point, the littlest one, the little boy, is being flung around a little too hard.
所以观众，我想，在这个时刻是非常宽容和理解的。但在这第一个开场场景中有一个时刻让观众注意到了。那就是，当孩子们上下猛拉、来回摆动、绕着这些椭圆转时，在某一点上，最小的那个，小男孩，被甩得太厉害了。
Well, he has the least mass to resist whatever the machinery is doing to him.
嗯，他抵抗机器对他所做的一切的质量最少。
Right.
对。
Mm-hm. OK. So, and?
嗯。好的。那么呢？
And so he's flying around in this circle. And the audience sees this coming. And there's a real sense of pain and gripping of the chair and white knuckle-ness as the kid suddenly does just an enormous splat into the wardrobe. And it's clear that he's hurt, and he comes off of it a little dazed. Then, of course, he's jerked up in the air a little bit, and often a little too high, so that he's suddenly in the workings. He left the stage itself. He's now up there with the lights. Then, all of a sudden he would just plummet back down to the stage and be caught up just before he hit the floor.
所以他绕着圈飞。观众看到了这一点。有一种真正的痛苦感，紧抓椅子和手关节发白的感觉，因为孩子突然猛地撞到了衣柜上。很明显他受伤了，他从上面下来时有点发晕。然后，当然，他被拉到空中一点，通常拉得太高了，以至于他突然进入了机关里。他离开了舞台本身。他现在在那上面，和灯光在一起。然后，突然间他会猛地跌回舞台，在碰到地板之前被接住。
It was hard to watch, because, as you can tell, it's an incredibly funny moment, but like I say, the audience was still in this very forgiving mode. And no one said a word. We just all sat there, holding our breath. And there's that weird tension of being in the audience, thinking, oh, oh my goodness. They have gotten off to a very bad start. Oh, this is not good. And we feel for them.
这很难看，因为如你所见，这是一个非常搞笑的时刻，但就像我说的，观众仍然处于这种非常宽容的模式。没有人说一句话。我们只是坐在那里，屏住呼吸。而且在观众席上有一种奇怪的紧张感，心想，哦，天哪。他们开局非常糟糕。哦，这不太好。我们为他们感到难过。
May I just interrupt for just a moment to just say, now at this point-- because after all, we are not just joined here together on the radio, you and I today, to laugh at the foibles of the unfortunate. No, no. We're here to enumerate the qualities of a fiasco. At this point, we are not yet in the territory of fiasco.
我可以打断一下吗，说一下，现在在这一点上——因为毕竟，我们今天聚在这里不是为了嘲笑不幸者的怪癖。不，不。我们在这里列举惨败的特质。在这一点上，我们还没有进入惨败的领域。
No. No, because, like I say, audiences are forgiving. One or two mistakes, even big ones like this, they are going to let that ride.
不。不，因为，就像我说的，观众是宽容的。一两个错误，甚至是像这样的大错误，他们会放过的。
Yes, they are.
是的，他们会。
We did. We did. We were very good.
我们做到了。我们做到了。我们非常好。
So we are not yet at fiasco. We are at a normal level of mishap.
所以我们还没有到惨败的程度。我们处于普通事故的水平。
Right. What happens immediately after this, they disappear to Never Never Land. And if you remember, the stage goes dark. And then when the lights come up, there's Captain Hook. And he's giving his first opening soliloquy about how evil he is and what a menace he is and how he harms people and hates children. It's all that good stuff.
对。这之后发生的事情是，他们消失到了梦幻岛。如果你还记得，舞台变暗了。然后当灯光亮起时，是铁钩船长。他正在做他的第一次开场独白，关于他是多么邪恶，他是一个多么大的威胁，他如何伤害他人和憎恨孩子。都是那些好东西。
And so Captain Hook is out there, and he looks great. He's got one of those big, old, fat hats and this great hook and these wild-looking boots and everything.
所以铁钩船长在那儿，他看起来很棒。他戴着那种大大的、旧的、肥大的帽子，还有这个很棒的钩子，以及这些看起来狂野的靴子等等。
And people are feeling more confident. Something's happening.
人们感觉更有信心了。有什么事情发生了。
It's a good sign. It's a good sign. And he's in charge. This guy, he's got a bad mustache, and he is certainly evil. And the audience is totally in his pocket. He's speaking away and gesturing wildly and going on and on about how bad he is.
这是一个好兆头。这是一个好兆头。他负责。这家伙，他留着一撇坏胡子，他当然是邪恶的。观众完全被他迷住了。他侃侃而谈，动作狂野，喋喋不休地说他有多坏。
And then at a certain point, as he gestures, his hook and the entire black casing up to his elbow flings off of his hand and flies into the audience and punches an old lady in the gut.
然后到了某个时刻，当他做手势时，他的钩子和一直到肘部的整个黑色外壳从他手上飞了出去，飞向观众席，打中了一位老太太的肚子。
He is bad.
他确实很坏。
He is very bad. He had the worst ad lib I've ever heard. I mean, what do you say at that point? Because, of course, his hand is now nakedly exposed to the audience.
他非常坏。他说了我听过的最糟糕的即兴台词。我的意思是，那种时候你能说什么？因为，当然，他的手现在赤裸裸地暴露在观众面前。
A tough moment for any actor.
对任何演员来说都是一个艰难的时刻。
Very, very hard.
非常，非常艰难。
If the very premise of your character is that you have a hook, your name is Captain Hook, literally all that's going to happen for the rest of the show is people are going to refer to you by that hook. Your entire motivation as a character is the fact that your arm was eaten off by an alligator and that you have to have a hook.
如果你的角色的前提是你有一个钩子，你的名字叫铁钩船长，字面上看，演出余下的时间里人们只会用那个钩子来指代你。作为角色的全部动机就是你的手臂被鳄鱼吃掉了，你必须有一个钩子。
The entire plot stems from that fact.
整个情节都源于那个事实。
Right. And now, suddenly, you have no hook.
对。现在，突然，你没有钩子了。
In fact, you have five fingers on a hand.
事实上，你的手上只有五根手指。
As if a miracle by the Lord.
仿佛上帝的奇迹。
Captain Hook said, "You know, they just don't make those hooks like they used to." That was actually the ad lib. I will never forget it. Then the lights come up, and we are in Never Never Land.
铁钩船长说：“你知道，他们就是做不出以前那种钩子了。”那实际上是即兴台词。我永远不会忘记它。然后灯光亮起，我们在梦幻岛。
In Act Two.
在第二幕。
Yeah, this is Act Two. And Captain Hook might have stood in front of the set, but you didn't really see it, because he spoke from shadow. And now the lights come up. And this is supposed to be a very dramatic moment.
是的，这是第二幕。铁钩船长可能站在布景前，但你并没有真正看到它，因为他在阴影中说话。现在灯光亮起。这本该是一个非常戏剧性的时刻。
The rumors of all this crew and the painting and everything that was going on and all this construction all worked towards this one moment, because when the lights came up, here was Never Never Land, this sort of psychedelic set. There were papier-mache mushrooms everywhere of different sizes. It was absolutely wonderful and surreal.
关于所有这些剧组、绘画和正在发生的一切以及所有这些施工的传言都指向这一个时刻，因为当灯光亮起时，这里就是梦幻岛，这种迷幻的布景。到处都是不同大小的纸糊蘑菇。它绝对美妙而超现实。
And there's nobody there. And then from the upper rafters of stage right, suddenly the kids and Peter Pan appear.
那里没有人。然后从舞台右侧的上层椽子上，孩子们和彼得·潘突然出现了。
Flying.
飞着。
Flying. They're flying. And their landing occurs rather rapidly, at an angle of about 45 degrees to the stage. They come down basically like, I don't know, lead sinkers on a line, and crash to the floor, and then are just dragged across the floor like mops and wipe out all of the mushrooms.
飞着。他们飞着。他们的着陆相当迅速，以大约45度的角度撞向舞台。他们基本就像，我不知道，线上的铅坠一样落下来，撞到地板上，然后像拖把一样被拖过地板，把所有的蘑菇都撞倒了。
And so now, have we arrived at a turning point in our fiasco?
所以现在，我们到达惨败的转折点了吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it's clear now that the audience is giving way. Something has been lost. Some sense of decorum, that little bit of forgiveness that the audience has for the actors--
是的。是的，现在很清楚观众正在放弃。有些东西丢失了。某种礼仪感，观众对演员的那一点宽容——
And empathy.
还有同理心。
--and empathy. It's beginning to dissipate. Well, there was a split in the audience. The younger people, who were the least forgiving, they started to go first. OK, so the high school students, a couple of college students, maybe, they started to laugh out loud.
——还有同理心。它开始消散。嗯，观众中有分裂。年轻人，他们是最不宽容的，他们开始先走。好的，所以高中生，几个大学生，也许，他们开始大声笑出来。
And I'll be honest, Ira, I might have been one of those first people to laugh. I was in the 10th grade. It was hard to not laugh at this thing. But then, whatever restraint that the audience had, it just evaporated at this point, because there were a number of things that happened in quick succession that just made it impossible to hold any sense of decorum.
老实说，艾拉，我可能是那些先笑的人之一。我上十年级。很难不对这东西不笑。但后来，无论观众有什么克制，此时此刻都烟消云散了，因为接连发生了一些事情，让人无法保持任何礼仪感。
Which are?
是什么？
For example, Tinker Bell appears for the first time around this moment. And Tinker Bell is essentially a light bulb on an extension cord.
例如，小叮当在这一刻第一次出现。而小叮当本质上是一个挂在延长线上的灯泡。
What?
什么？
Yeah. And this was the director's idea of being raw, being very modern. Tinker Bell was just going to be this literal light bulb, dangling from an extension cord.
是的。这是导演认为原始、非常现代的想法。小叮当只是那个从延长线上垂下的文字灯泡。
Whereas, in other productions, what they'll do is that someone will shine a light.
而在其他作品中，他们会做的是有人照一束光。
Shine a light, or they'll just--
照一束光，或者他们只是——
A beam of focused light. And then that pinprick of light is supposed to be Tinker Bell.
一束聚焦的光。然后那一点光被认为是小叮当。
That's right, or something like that, or nothing at all, and people just address the invisible sprite. Well, that did not happen in this case. This bulb comes just dangling down and sort of hangs around this naked--
没错，或者类似的东西，或者什么都没有，人们只是对着看不见的精灵说话。好吧，这次没发生这种情况。这个灯泡只是垂下来，悬在那个赤裸的——
A bare light bulb?
一个裸露的灯泡？
--white bulb just hangs around. And people are talking to it. And I think Tinker Bell must have had an appearance in the first act. But it was somewhere in here that people just started laughing at this.
——白色灯泡只是悬在那里。人们对着它说话。我想小叮当一定在第一幕出现过。但就在这里，人们开始嘲笑它。
Then another thing that happened was, later on in this scene, if you remember, Wendy gets trapped on an island. And she spots a kite that's flying by. And she's supposed to grab it and attach it to her back and fly off. Well, of course, the kite is attached to the flying apparatus line. And it gets closer and closer to her. She's standing on this little papier-mache hill.
然后发生的另一件事是，在这个场景的后面，如果你记得，温迪被困在一个岛上。她发现了一只飞过的风筝。她本该抓住它并把它系在背上飞走。好吧，当然，风筝系在飞行设备的线上。它离她越来越近。她站在那个小纸糊的小山上。
But the flying apparatus people can't quite get it close enough to her to reach. So she has to step out into the waters that she's just told us is filled with crocodiles to grab it. She finally gets the kite, and when she yanks on it, it pops off the flying apparatus. And the hook goes zinging up into the lights and catches.
但飞行设备的人没法把它弄得足够靠近让她够到。所以她必须踏入她刚刚告诉我们充满鳄鱼的水中去抓它。她终于拿到了风筝，当她猛拉它时，它从飞行设备上弹了出来。钩子呼啸着飞入灯光中并挂住了。
So now there is this big loop of wire hanging in front of the stage. And there's Wendy, holding the kite. And she ad libbed as best she could, as I remember. She said, "On second thought, maybe I can swim." And with that, she walked off the stage, motioning her arms like you would do the swim, the dance, in 1965.
所以现在舞台前面挂着一大圈电线。温迪拿着风筝。她尽可能地即兴发挥了，我记得。她说：“转念一想，也许我可以游泳。”说完，她走下舞台，像1965年的舞蹈动作那样挥舞着手臂。
So she does that. At this point, the actors are just falling apart. They are so frightened of the audience. There are just belly laughs rolling up to the stage from the audience. People are howling with laughter at every mistake.
所以她做了。此时，演员们完全崩溃了。他们非常害怕观众。从观众席滚向舞台的只有大笑声。人们对每一个错误都笑得打滚。
And now any small mistake just takes on these-- any instigation for laughter is just enough of for this audience. And now the old people have given it up. Everyone has quit being nice. Now there's just this kind of frightening roar that comes from the audience every time there's a mistake.
现在任何小错误都带着这些——任何引人发笑的东西对这个观众群来说都足够了。现在老年人也放弃了。每个人都不再友好了。现在，每次有错误时，观众席中就会传出一种可怕的咆哮。
Well, what happened? At some point the audience turned and realized, oh wait. I realize what's going on here. This is a fiasco.
嗯，发生了什么？在某个时刻，观众转过身意识到，哦等等。我意识到这里发生了什么。这是一场惨败。
Yeah. This is a fiasco. And what's really interesting about a fiasco is that once it starts to tumble down, the audience wants to push it further along.
是的。这是一场惨败。而关于惨败真正有趣的是，一旦它开始坍塌，观众就想把它推得更远。
Oh, they get hungry for more fiasco.
哦，他们渴望更多的惨败。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
If the play proceeded perfectly, they would be disappointed.
如果这出戏进行得完美，他们会感到失望。
Oh, it would have been a grave disappointment had not been just one more mistake after another, one more embarrassment after another. Now the reason they're there is to chronicle these embarrassments. This is why I have remembered this play for 25 years.
哦，如果不是一个接一个的错误，一个接一个的尴尬，那将是极大的失望。现在他们在那儿的原因是记录这些尴尬。这就是我记得这出戏25年的原因。
Towards Act Three, Ira, the director had decided that she wanted to break down the fourth wall. This was cutting-edge theater, as far as she was concerned.
在第三幕之前，艾拉，导演决定她想打破第四堵墙。就她而言，这是前沿戏剧。
Before you do this, I just want to explain. When we say breaking down the fourth wall, what we mean is the wall between the actors and the audience. Usually it's impermeable, but then there came a point in the late '60s, early '70s, where a lot of theaters-- basically, the actors would come out into the audience.
在你这样做之前，我只想解释一下。当我们说打破第四堵墙时，我们指的是演员和观众之间的墙。通常它是不可逾越的，但在60年代末、70年代初，出现了一个点，许多剧院——基本上，演员会走到观众席中。
That's right, and interact with the audience and break down that wall. So the idea being that you would get more in touch with the dramatic sense and the reality of what was happening.
没错，与观众互动并打破那堵墙。所以想法是，你会更多地接触到戏剧感和正在发生的事情的现实。
Anyway, so in this particular scene, what was going to happen was that the Indians were going to throw rope ladders down from the balcony and climb down these rope ladders into the audience and move among the audience in their very scary, savage way and frighten us. Anyway, I know about this scene, because my friend David, who I went to high school with, was in it.
总之，在这个特定的场景中，将要发生的是印第安人会从阳台上扔下绳梯，爬下这些绳梯进入观众席，以他们非常可怕、野蛮的方式在观众中穿行并吓唬我们。总之，我知道这个场景，因为我高中时的朋友大卫在里面。
So when David was climbing over the top of this balcony to climb down the rope, he lost his footing and fell to the floor from the balcony, a distance of about 15 to 20 feet.
所以当大卫爬过这个阳台顶部去爬绳子时，他失去了平衡，从阳台上掉到了地板上，距离大约15到20英尺。
Oh my god.
天哪。
A good fall.
摔得不轻。
That's horrible.
那太可怕了。
Yeah. And he landed on both of his feet and sprained both of his ankles and, of course, curled into a fetal position and began to cry. He was really, really hurt.
是的。他双脚着地，扭伤了双脚踝，当然，蜷缩成胎儿姿势开始哭。他真的，真的受伤了。
Now, to appreciate the horrible moment I'm now describing, also understand that it's a Friday night. We are in a college town. And there is a volunteer fire and ambulance department. And in order to summon the rescuers from wherever they are, an alarm is sounded that can be heard for five miles. That alarm is located right over this theater.
现在，要体会我现在描述的那个可怕时刻，也要明白这是一个周五晚上。我们在一个大学城。那里有志愿消防和救护部门。为了从他们所在的地方召唤救援人员，会响起一个可以在五英里外听到的警报。那个警报就位于这个剧院上方。
So the alarm goes off, OK? This is an air raid siren. It is so loud, you can put your fingers in your ear, and it's still hurting your ears. We're right under it. It can be heard for five miles.
所以警报响了，好吗？这是一个空袭警报。它太响了，你把手指塞进耳朵里，它仍然在伤害你的耳朵。我们就直接在它下面。它可以在五英里外听到。
And then, of course, three minutes later, busting through the door of the theater are these 15 firemen who are in boots, hats. They've got hoses. They don't know what it is. All they know is that they've been sent out on a call. And to add to the chaos, the director, of course, has flogged the actors that the show must go on.
然后，当然，三分钟后，闯入剧院门的是这15个消防员，他们穿着靴子，戴着帽子。他们拿着软管。他们不知道是什么。他们只知道他们被派去执行任务。为了增加混乱，导演当然鞭策演员演出必须继续。
No matter what.
无论如何。
No matter what. So while all of this is happening-- and several people are attending to David. And other people have just now decided that since the firemen are here, he's going to be fine. They can start laughing. And now the audience has just completely lost control.
无论如何。所以当这一切发生时——几个人正在照顾大卫。而其他人现在已经决定，既然消防员在这儿，他会没事的。他们可以开始笑了。现在观众已经完全失去了控制。
People are standing up in their seats and shouting for more. They want blood. At this point, people are actually injured in the production. And they want more. Somehow, that's how this entire play ended.
人们从座位上站起来大喊要更多。他们想要血。在这一点上，实际上有人在演出中受伤了。而他们想要更多。不知何故，这出戏就是这样结束的。
What's interesting about that this as a fiasco, I feel like the thing it makes me understand about fiascoes, is that the fiasco itself is an altered state. That is, all the normal rules are off. You have left the normal rules of how the audience is going to interact with the actors.
作为一场惨败，有趣的是，我觉得关于惨败让我明白的事情是，惨败本身是一种改变的状态。也就是说，所有正常的规则都不适用了。你已经离开了观众将如何与演员互动的正常规则。
Right. I've never seen a production like this. And I've never seen an audience collapse like this.
对。我从未见过这样的制作。我也从未见过观众像这样崩溃。
See, but I wonder, when you think about what people go to theater for, what kind of release people want, people want an experience that will take them out of themselves. We all want an experience that would take us out of ourselves and into another place in another reality. And it sounds like this production, even though it was a fiasco-- in fact, because it was a fiasco-- was more successful at that than any conventional play could be.
你看，但我怀疑，当你想到人们去剧院是为了什么，人们想要什么样的释放时，人们想要一种能让他们摆脱自我的体验。我们都想要一种能让我们摆脱自我进入另一个现实中的另一个地方的体验。听起来这部作品，尽管它是一场惨败——事实上，因为它是一场惨败——在这一点上比任何传统戏剧都更成功。
Well, see, I have to disagree with you there. I think the old theater critics, the ancients, would say that the reason you go to the theater and to see a great production is to be, I think the word these used to use is "transported." The idea being that you would be lifted away from your animal nature and into these higher, more spiritual realms, or get in touch with these greater, tragic emotions, right? But of course, what happened here was the exact opposite. We got transported directly in touch with our animal being.
好吧，你看，我不得不和你意见相左。我认为老戏剧评论家，古人，会说你去剧院看一场伟大的演出是为了，我想他们过去用的词是“被带走”。想法是，你会远离你的动物本性，进入这些更高、更精神的领域，或者接触到这些更伟大的悲剧性情感，对吧？但当然，这里发生的事情恰恰相反。我们被直接带到接触我们的动物本质。
Our baser selves.
我们的卑劣自我。
Right. But that's almost as rare, if not more so, than a great production.
对。但这几乎和一场伟大的演出一样罕见，如果不更罕见的话。
Jack Hitt. He normally writes for The New York Times Magazine and The New Yorker.
杰克·希特。他通常为《纽约时报杂志》和《纽约客》撰稿。
[MUSIC - "I WON'T GROW UP" BY RICKIE LEE JONES]
[音乐 - 瑞奇·李·琼斯演唱的“我不会长大”]
Act Two, What We Wanted To Do. With some fiascoes, all social order breaks down. With others, a thing that you're trying to create simply refuses to be created. This next fiasco falls into that second category. Ron Carlson wrote this story. Jeff Dorchen reads it.
第二幕，我们想做什么。对于一些惨败，所有社会秩序都崩溃了。对于另一些，你试图创造的东西拒绝被创造出来。接下来的这个惨败属于第二类。罗恩·卡尔森（Ron Carlson）写了这个故事。杰夫·多琴（Jeff Dorchen）读了它。
What we wanted to do was spill boiling oil onto the heads of our enemies as they attempted to bang down the gates of our village. But, as everyone now knows, we had some problems, primarily technical problems, that prevented us from doing what we wanted to do the way we had hoped to do it. What we're asking for today is another chance.
我们想做的是把沸油泼在我们敌人的头上，当他们试图撞倒我们村庄的大门时。但是，正如现在每个人都知道的那样，我们遇到了一些问题，主要是技术问题，阻止了我们以我们希望的方式做我们想做的事。我们今天要求的是另一次机会。
There has been so much media attention to this boiling oil issue that it is time to clear the air. There's a great deal of pressure to dismantle the system we have in place and bring the oil down off the roof. This would be a mistake.
关于这个沸油问题有太多的媒体关注，是时候澄清事实了。有巨大的压力要拆除我们到位的系统并将油从屋顶上取下来。这将是一个错误。
Yes, there were problems last month during the Visigoth raid. But as I will note, these are easily remedied. From its inception, I have been intimately involved with the boiling oil project-- research, development, physical deployment. I also happened to be team leader on the roof last month when we had occasion to try the system during the Visigoth attack about which so much has been written.
是的，上个月在西哥特人袭击期间出现了问题。但正如我将指出的，这些很容易补救。从一开始，我就深入参与了这个沸油项目——研究、开发、物理部署。上个月当我们在西哥特人袭击期间有机会尝试该系统时，我也恰好是屋顶上的团队负责人，关于这一点已经写了很多报道。
First, the very concept of oil on the roof upset many of our villagers. Granted, it is exotic. But all great ideas seem strange at first. When our researchers realize we could position a cauldron 200 feet directly above our main portals, they began to see the possibilities of the greatest strategic defense system in the history of mankind. But at every turn we've met problems that our researchers could not, despite their intelligence and intuition, have foreseen.
首先，屋顶上有油的概念让许多村民感到不安。当然，它是异国情调的。但所有伟大的想法起初看起来都很奇怪。当我们的研究人员意识到我们可以把一口大锅放在我们主入口上方200英尺处时，他们开始看到人类历史上最伟大的战略防御系统的可能性。但我们在每一步都遇到了我们的研究人员尽管有他们的智慧和直觉也无法预见的问题。
For instance, how were we to get a 1,9000-pound brass cauldron onto the roof? In the end, the cauldron was raised to the roof by means of a custom-designed net and petard under less than ideal conditions. The Retrogoths and the Nilogoths plundered our village almost incessantly during the cauldron's four-month ascent.
例如，我们如何把一口1900磅重的黄铜大锅弄到屋顶上？最后，大锅是在不理想的条件下通过定制设计的网和彼得炮升到屋顶的。当大锅四个月的上升过程中，Retrogoths和Nilogoths几乎不断地掠夺我们的村庄。
The cauldron's arrival on the roof was quite a moment. I remember it well. We stood by that gleaming symbol of our impending safety, a bright brass beacon to the world that we were not going to take it anymore. The wind carried up to us the cries of villagers being carried away by either the Maxigoths or the Minigoths.
大锅到达屋顶是一个重要的时刻。我记得很清楚。我们站在那个即将到来的安全的闪亮象征旁，一个向世界发出的明亮黄铜灯塔，表明我们再也不会忍受了。风把被Maxigoths或Minigoths带走的村民的呼喊声传给我们。
But there we stood. As I felt the wind in my hair and watched the sporadic procession of home furnishings being carried out of our violated gates, I knew we were perched on the edge of a new epoch.
但我们就站在那里。当我感觉到风吹过我的头发，看着家里的家具被断断续续地从我们被侵犯的大门搬走时，我知道我们正站在一个新时代的边缘。
Well, there was some excitement. We began at once. We started a fire under the cauldron. And we knew we would all soon be safe. At that point, I made a mistake, which I now readily admit. In the utter ebullience of the moment, I called down. I did not scream maniacally, as was reported. I called down that it would not be long. And I probably shouldn't have, because it may have led some of our citizenry to lower their guard. It was a mistake. I admit it.
嗯，有一些兴奋。我们立刻开始了。我们在大锅下生了火。我们知道我们很快就会安全。在那一刻，我犯了一个错误，我现在很容易承认。在这一刻的极度亢奋中，我向下喊。我并没有像报道的那样狂乱地尖叫。我向下喊道不会很久了。我可能不应该这样做，因为它可能导致我们的一些公民降低警惕。这是一个错误。我承认。
There were, as we found almost immediately, still some bugs to be worked out of the program. For instance, there had never been a fire on top of the entry tower before. And yes, as everyone is aware, we had to spend more time than we really wanted containing the blaze, fueled as it was by the fresh high winds and the tower's wooden shingles. I hasten to add that the damage was moderate, as moderate as a four-hour fire could be.
正如我们几乎立即发现的那样，程序中仍然有一些漏洞需要解决。例如，入口塔顶上以前从未生过火。是的，正如每个人都知道的那样，我们不得不花费比我们真正想要的更多的时间来控制大火，因为它是由新鲜的强风和塔楼的木瓦助燃的。我赶紧补充说，损失是温和的，像一场四小时的火灾所能有的那样温和。
But throughout this relentless series of setbacks, pitfalls, and rooftop fires, there has been a hard core of us absolutely dedicated to doing what we wanted to do, to splash scalding oil onto intruders as they pried or battered, yet again, at our old damaged gates. It was a little fire on the rooftop. It was of no consequence, a fribble, a tiny obstacle to be stepped over with an easy stride.
但在这一系列无情的挫折、陷阱和屋顶火灾中，我们有一小群核心人物完全致力于做我们想做的事，向闯入者泼洒滚烫的油，当他们再次撬开或撞击我们旧的损坏的大门时。那是屋顶上的一个小火。它无关紧要，一个琐事，一个轻松跨过的小障碍。
Were we tired? Were we dirty? Were some of us burned and cranky? No matter. We were committed. And so the next day, the first quiet day we'd had in this village in months, that same sooty cadre stood in the warm ashes high above the entry steps and tried again.
我们累了吗？我们脏了吗？我们中有些人被烧伤了吗？没关系。我们致力于此。所以第二天，我们在那个村庄几个月来第一个安静的日子里，那群满是煤烟的骨干站在入口台阶上方温暖的灰烬中，再次尝试。
We knew, as we know right now, that our enemies are manifold and voracious and generally rude and persistent. And we wanted to be ready. But tell me this. Where does one find out how soon before an enemy attack to put the oil on to boil? Does anyone know? Let me assure you, it is not in any book. We were writing the book.
我们知道，正如我们现在所知道的那样，我们的敌人是多样的、贪婪的，而且通常是粗鲁和执着的。我们想做好准备。但告诉我这个。人们在哪里能找到在敌人袭击前多久把油放上去烧？有人知道吗？让我向你保证，这不在任何书里。我们正在写那本书。
We were vigilant. We squinted at the horizon all day long. And when we first saw the dust in the foothills, we fired our cauldron, using wood that had been elevated through the night in woven baskets. Even speaking about it here today, I can feel the excitement stirring in my heart. The orange flames licked the sides of the brass container hungrily, as if in concert with our own desperate desire for security and revenge.
我们保持警惕。我们整天眯着眼看着地平线。当我们第一次在山脚下看到灰尘时，我们点燃了大锅，使用了通宵通过编织篮子抬上来的木头。即使今天在这里谈论它，我也能感觉到兴奋在我心中涌动。橙色的火焰贪婪地舔着黄铜容器的侧面，仿佛与我们自己对安全和复仇的绝望渴望相呼应。
In the distance, I could see the phalanx of Visigoths marching toward us like a warship through a sea of dust. And in my soul, I pitied them and the end toward which they so steadfastly hastened. They seemed the very incarnation of mistake, their dreams of a day abusing our friends and families and of petty arson and lewd public behavior about to be extinguished in one gorgeous wash of searing oil. I was beside myself.
在远处，我可以看到西哥特人的方阵像海中的军舰一样穿过尘土向我们行进。在我的灵魂深处，我怜悯他们，怜悯他们如此坚定地奔向的终点。他们看起来简直就是错误的化身，他们对一天之内虐待我们的朋友和家人、进行轻微纵火和淫秽公开行为的梦想即将在这一波壮丽的灼热油中熄灭。我当时忘乎所以。
It is important to know now that everyone on the roof that day exhibited orderly and methodical behavior. There was no wild screaming or cursing or even the kind of sarcastic chuckling you might expect in those about to enjoy a well-deserved and long-delayed victory. The problems of the day were not attributable to inappropriate deportment. My staff was good.
现在重要的是要知道，那天屋顶上的每个人都表现得有条不紊。没有疯狂的尖叫或咒骂，甚至没有你可能预料到的那些即将享受当之无愧和姗姗来迟的胜利的人那种讽刺的笑声。当天的各种问题不能归因于不当行为。我的团队很好。
It was when the Visigoths had approached close enough that we could see their cruel eyes and we could read their savage and misspelled tattoos that I realized our error. At that time, I put my hand on the smooth side of our beautiful cauldron and found it only vaguely warm, lukewarm, tepid. We had not known then what we now know. We need to put the oil on soon. It was my decision and my decision alone to do what we did, and that was to pour the warm oil on our enemies as they milled about the front gates, hammering at it with their truncheons.
当西哥特人接近到我们可以看到他们残酷的眼睛，可以读懂他们野蛮且拼写错误的纹身时，我意识到我们的错误。当时，我把手放在我们美丽大锅的光滑侧面上，发现它只是隐约温暖，温热，不温不火。我们当时不知道现在知道的事。我们需要快点把油放上去。是我决定并独自决定做我们所做的事，那就是把温油泼在我们的敌人身上，当他们在前门附近徘徊时，用他们的警棍敲打着大门。
Now, this is where my report diverges from so many of the popular accounts. We have heard it said that the warm oil served as a stimulant to the attack that followed, the attack I alluded to earlier, in which the criminal activity seemed even more animated than usual in the minds of some of our townspeople. Let me say first, I was an eyewitness. I gave the order to pour the oil and I witnessed its descent.
现在，这就是我的报告与许多流行叙述分歧的地方。我们听说温油成了随后袭击的兴奋剂，也就是我之前提到的袭击，其中犯罪活动在一些城镇居民看来似乎比平时更活跃。首先让我说，我是目击者。我下令泼油，我目睹了它的下降。
I am happy and proud to report that the oil hit its target with an accuracy and completeness I could have only dreamed of. We got them all. There was oil everywhere. We soaked them. We coated them. We covered them with a lustrous layer of oil. Unfortunately, as everyone knows, it was only warm.
我很高兴和自豪地报告，油以我只能梦想的准确性和完整性击中了目标。我们击中了他们所有人。到处都是油。我们浸透了他们。我们覆盖了他们。我们用一层光亮的油覆盖了他们。不幸的是，正如每个人都知道的那样，它只是温暖的。
Their immediate reaction was also what I had hoped for, surprise and panic. This, however, lasted about one second. Then, several of them looked up into my face and began waving their fists in what I could only take as a tribute. And then, yes, they did become quite agitated anew, recommencing their assault on the weary planks of our patchwork gates. Some have said that they were on the verge of abandoning their attack before the oil was cast upon them, which I assure you is not true.
他们的即时反应也正如我所希望的那样，惊讶和恐慌。然而，这只持续了一秒钟。然后，他们中的几个人抬头看着我的脸，开始挥舞拳头，我只能将其视为一种敬礼。然后，是的，他们确实再次变得相当激动，重新开始对我们拼凑大门的疲惫木板进行攻击。有些人说在油倒在他们身上之前他们正处于放弃攻击的边缘，我向你保证这不是真的。
As to the attack that followed, it was no different in magnitude or intensity than any of the dozens we suffer every year. It may have seemed more odd or extreme, since the perpetrators were greasy and thereby more offensive. And they did take every stick of furniture left in the village, including the pews from the church, every chair in the great hall, and four milking stools, the last four from the dairy.
至于随后的袭击，其规模或强度与我们每年遭受的几十次袭击没有什么不同。这看起来可能更奇怪或极端，因为作案者是油腻的，因此更具冒犯性。他们确实拿走了村里剩下的每一件家具，包括教堂的长椅、大厅里的每一把椅子，以及四个挤奶凳，这是乳制品厂最后的四个。
But I, for one, am simply tired of hearing about the slippery stain on the village steps. Yes, there is a bit of a mess. And yes, some of it seems to be permanent. My team removed what they could with salt and talc all this week. All I'll say now is watch your step as you come and go. In my mind, it's a small inconvenience to pay for a perfect weapon system.
但我个人对于听到关于村口台阶上的滑腻污渍感到厌倦。是的，有点乱。是的，有些似乎是永久性的。我的团队这周用盐和滑石粉清除了他们能清除的所有东西。我现在唯一要说的是，来来往往时注意脚下。在我看来，为一个完美的武器系统付出一点点不便代价是很小的。
"What We Wanted to Do" is from Ron Carlson's book of short stories called Hotel Eden. Ron's latest book is Return to Oakpine.
“我们想做的事”出自罗恩·卡尔森的短篇小说集《伊甸园酒店》。罗恩最新的书是《回归奥克派恩》。
Coming up, man versus squirrel, specifically cop versus squirrel. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，人与松鼠，具体来说是警察与松鼠。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Fiasco, our own inquiry into the nature of what makes a fiasco, when you have left the world of mishaps, stumble, human error, and you enter into the much more rarefied realm of fiasco. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Squirrel Cop.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，《惨败》，我们对什么是惨败本质的调查，当你离开了事故、绊倒、人为错误的领域，进入了更稀有的惨败领域。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，松鼠警察。
Well, human error is often at the heart of a fiasco. But what happens when you combine human error with, what we will call in this case, animal error? We have this story from a police officer in a suburban community on the East Coast.
好吧，人为错误通常是惨败的核心。但是当你把人为错误与我们在此情况下称之为动物错误的东西结合起来时会发生什么？我们有这个来自东海岸郊区社区一名警官的故事。
There was nothing, nothing going on. Saturday night in this village. Really quiet. Super cold. And this call came over for unknown animal in a house. And it was on my post. It was about five minutes away.
什么都没有，什么都没有发生。在这个村庄的周六晚上。真的很安静。超级冷。这个关于屋子里有不明动物的电话打过来了。它在我的辖区。大约五分钟路程。
So myself and another car were assigned the call. And we show up there. And luckily for me, it was another guy who was pretty new. So we walk up to the door with all our stuff on, the nylon coat, the vest, the belt, the whole nine yards.
所以我和另一辆车被指派处理这个电话。我们出现在那里。幸运的是对我来说，那是另一个相当新的家伙。所以我们带着我们所有的东西走上门，尼龙外套，背心，腰带，全套装备。
And the door opens, and the guy who is behind the door, he's about 30. I was 23 at the time. He's about 30. He looks like a broker, a lawyer. He's just really well put together, a nice guy wearing glasses.
门开了，门后的那个人大约30岁。我当时23岁。他大约30岁。他看起来像个经纪人，律师。他整个人打理得很好，是个戴着眼镜的好人。
He's wearing these, like, silk pajamas with a monogram, got my attention. And he's going, listen I'm really sorry to bother you. Normally, I'd handle this sort of stuff on my own. But my wife really insisted I call.
他穿着这些，像带字母组合的丝绸睡衣，吸引了我的注意。他说，听着，我真的很抱歉打扰你们。通常，我会自己处理这种事。但我妻子真的坚持要我打电话。
So we ask him what the problem is. He says, well, we were having kind of a romantic evening down in the living room, and we heard a scratching upstairs. So I ran upstairs to see what it was. And it turns out it's coming from the attic. There's something up there. And it's just running around, knocking a few small things over. I can't tell what it is. It could be a squirrel, a raccoon. I really don't know.
所以我们问他问题是什么。他说，嗯，我们在客厅度过了一个浪漫的夜晚，我们听到楼上有抓挠声。所以我跑上楼去看是什么。结果是从阁楼传来的。上面有什么东西。它只是在上面跑来跑去，撞倒了一些小东西。我看不出是什么。可能是松鼠，浣熊。我真的不知道。
So the other cop that I was with said, well, you know, we really don't handle that. It's not so much a police function. But we do have numbers of these private contractors who will come in and they'll put a humane trap down, and they'll remove the animal for you. And it's really not such a big deal. But it's really not our thing.
所以我同行的另一个警察说，好吧，你知道，我们真的不处理这个。这不是太多的警察职能。但我们确实有这些私人承包商的号码，他们会过来，他们会放一个诱捕器，他们会为你移走动物。这不是什么大不了的事。但这真的不是我们的事。
So right as he was in the middle of saying that and getting us off the hook, the guy swings the door back, and there's his wife, who was just beautiful. She was beautiful. She was probably about 26 or 27, but just really beautiful-- perfect skin, long blonde hair, great teeth, brilliant blue eyes, a really nice smile, just, like, beautiful and friendly. If she had said, eat this broken glass, I just would have said, OK, broken glass it is. That's fine.
就在他说到一半让我们解脱时，那个人把门向后一推，那是他的妻子，真是太美了。她很美。她可能大约26或27岁，但真的很美——完美的皮肤，长长的金发，漂亮的牙齿，明亮的蓝眼睛，真的很棒的微笑，就像，美丽又友好。如果她说，吃下这些碎玻璃，我只会说，好的，碎玻璃就是了。没关系。
But she seemed really nice. So I was going to be, like, Galahad. So I just threw my arm back into this guy's chest, into my partner's chest. And I said, Mark, we can handle this. It'll be OK.
但她看起来真的很好。所以我打算当，像，加拉哈德（Galahad）。所以我只是把我的胳膊甩回那个人的胸口，甩向我搭档的胸口。我说，马克，我们可以处理这个。会没事的。
And she was just, oh, thank you so much. And she was really sweet. And I was, like, struck dead. So we walk inside. And she goes, I'm going to throw a pot of coffee on. And we go upstairs. We follow the man of the house upstairs. And we're underneath one of those trapdoors that goes into the attic with the staircase that folds out.
她只是，哦，非常感谢你们。她真的很甜。我，像，被迷住了。所以我们走进去。她说，我去煮壶咖啡。我们上楼。我们跟着房主上楼。我们在一扇通往阁楼的活板门下面，楼梯折叠出来。
And we do hear an animal upstairs scratching away, just kind of scuttling around the floor. And there's definitely something up there. And it's making pretty good speed up, going from one end of the roof to the other. So I reached up and I took the trapdoor down. We unfolded the ladder.
我们确实听到楼上有动物在抓挠，只是在那儿跑来跑去。上面肯定有什么东西。它在那儿跑得相当快，从屋顶的一端跑到另一端。所以我伸手把活板门拉了下来。我们展开了梯子。
Now, I have this big, heavy flashlight, your cop flashlight, the four D-cells, the metal case, the whole thing. And I shine it up through the hole in there. And it's pretty black. I could see the rafters, but really nothing else around there. And I start up the ladder. Now, the guy who owned the house is standing almost directly underneath me, just to the side of the ladder, looking straight up at me. And my partner's at the base of the ladder, right behind me.
现在，我有这个大而沉重的手电筒，你的警察手电筒，四个D号电池，金属外壳，全套东西。我从那洞里向上照。上面很黑。我可以看到椽子，但周围真的什么也没有。我开始爬梯子。现在，拥有房子的那个家伙站在我正下方，就在梯子旁边，直直地看着我。我搭档在我身后的梯子底部。
So just before I stuck my head through this black hole, I just kind of paused. I crunched my body up underneath, because I'm realizing, gee, I don't know where this thing is. The second we pulled down the trapdoor, all noise upstairs just ceased.
就在我把头伸进这个黑洞之前，我只是停顿了一下。我把身体缩在这个洞下，因为我意识到，哎呀，我不知道这东西在哪儿。我们一拉下活板门，楼上的所有噪音都停止了。
So I was kind of nervous. And I was like, well, I look like an idiot just crouched up here on the top of the ladder. So I took the flashlight, and I just popped my head up, turned the light on again.
所以我有点紧张。我心想，好吧，我缩在梯子顶端看起来像个白痴。所以我拿出手电筒，我又打开灯，探出头去。
And about six inches from the front of my face was this squirrel at eye level with me, kind of reared back on its legs. And I swear, from where I was standing, it looked Godzilla. It just scared the heck out of me. I thought, it's a squirrel. It's going to hiding somewhere. It's going to be terrified of me. It was six inches away from me.
距离我的脸前大约六英寸，这只松鼠和我平视，有点后腿站立。我发誓，从我站的地方看，它看起来像哥斯拉。它吓坏我了。我想，这是一只松鼠。它会躲在某个地方。它会怕我怕得要命。它离我只有六英寸。
And it really startled me. So I kind of went, ah, and jump back. And the flashlight slips out of my hands. And it's heavy. And it falls directly onto the nose of the guy who's looking straight up at me. And I don't think it broke it, but it did some damage. And his hands went up to his face, blood just starting pouring out between his hands.
它确实吓了我一跳。所以我有点，啊，跳了回来。手电筒从我手中滑落。它很重。它直接掉在了直直看着我的那个家伙的鼻子上。我不认为它摔断了，但它造成了一些损坏。他的手捂住脸，血开始从指缝中涌出。
This is the homeowner.
这是房主。
This is the homeowner. I lose my balance and fall backwards, directly onto my partner. And I just pancake him. We're both on our backs. He's on his back. I'm on his stomach on my back, scuttling around like a beetle trying to get up in this really narrow hallway. It's a mess.
这是房主。我失去平衡向后倒，直接倒在我搭档身上。我只是像薄煎饼一样拍扁了他。我们都背朝地。他在他背上。我在他肚子上背朝地，像甲虫一样在这个非常狭窄的走廊里抓来抓去试图爬起来。一团糟。
The squirrel, while we're floundering around in the hallway, jumps down the stairs-- boink, boink, boink-- lands on me, and takes off down the stairs.
当我们在走廊里挣扎时，松鼠跳下楼梯——砰，砰，砰——落在我也身上，顺着楼梯跑了。
How undignified.
多没尊严啊。
It was terrible. It was terrible. So we're wondering, gee, where is the squirrel? And right at that second, the woman who lived there, you hear her scream. So my partner goes, well, we found the squirrel. It's wherever she is.
太糟糕了。太糟糕了。所以我们想，哎呀，松鼠在哪儿？就在那一秒，住在那里的人，你听到她尖叫。所以我搭档说，嗯，我们找到松鼠了。无论她在哪里它就在哪里。
So we go running downstairs. And the squirrel had come into the living room where they had been having their romantic evening. They a fire going. They had pillows arranged around one corner of the couch next to the fire. And they had champagne flutes out. Nice house, really nice, I mean, it just smelled brand new-- new carpeting, new rugs, new paint. They hadn't been there for that long.
所以我们跑下楼。松鼠进了客厅，他们本在那儿度过浪漫的夜晚。他们生着火。他们在沙发旁边火炉旁的一个角落里摆放着枕头。他们摆出了香槟杯。漂亮的房子，真的很好，我的意思是，它闻起来就像全新的——新地毯，新垫子，新油漆。他们搬进来没多久。
So the squirrel, when it bolted down the staircase, took off into the living room and ran underneath the couch for cover. So we run downstairs. This guy is bleeding all over the place on his carpets. His wife looks, and says, what have you done to my husband? I start going, oh, it was an accident. And then I just stop in mid-sentence. What's the point? We've only been there about two minutes.
所以松鼠，当它冲下楼梯时，跑进客厅，钻到沙发底下躲避。我们跑下楼。这家伙的地毯上满是血。他妻子看着，说，你们对我丈夫做了什么？我开始说，哦，这只是个意外。然后我半句话停住了。有什么意义？我们才在那里大约两分钟。
So the squirrel is underneath the couch. And my partner is going, let's get out of here. This is just-- it's not going well. So I'm not beaten yet. I always have another idea.
所以松鼠在沙发底下。我搭档说，走吧。这只是——进展不顺。所以我还没被打败。我总有另一个想法。
So the squirrel is under this couch, which is in the middle of the room. So I have this bright idea. Why don't we move the furniture away from one of the corners? And we'll put the couch in the corner. And the squirrel will probably move along with the couch, because it's the only cover available to it. And once we get into the corner, we'll only have two open sides of the couch to worry about. So we did that.
所以松鼠在这张沙发底下，沙发在房间中间。所以我有个好主意。为什么我们不把家具从一个角落移开？我们把沙发放在角落里。松鼠可能会随着沙发一起移动，因为那是它唯一可用的掩体。一旦我们到了角落，我们就只需要担心沙发的两个敞开侧面。所以我们这样做了。
That is so tactical.
那太有战术了。
Yes. Yeah, I was very proud of myself at that instant. But you know. I asked her for a box. And she says, sure, we've got boxes. We just moved in. We have nothing but boxes. She runs out to the garage, and she comes back with a box. And the box is long enough. And it fits across the entire short side of the couch, where the armrest would be.
是的。是的，那一刻我对自己很自豪。但你知道。我向她要一个盒子。她说，当然，我们有盒子。我们刚搬进来。我们除了盒子什么都没有。她跑到车库，带回来一个盒子。盒子够长。它横跨沙发的整个短边，也就是扶手的地方。
So I start sweeping underneath the couch with my nightstick, trying to move the squirrel toward the box, figuring we'll capture it and just get rid of it. And we'll be out of here. And there'll be no more mayhem.
所以我开始用我的警棍在沙发下扫，试图把松鼠推向盒子，想着我们会抓住它然后处理掉它。我们就会从这里出去。就不会有更多的骚乱了。
So it's actually working very well. And the squirrel is moving down along. You can hear it. It's chittering. And I'm trying not to hurt it. I'm nervous about the thing. It might bite me. I don't want to hurt it, really. It's just an animal.
所以实际上进展得非常好。松鼠沿着边移动。你可以听到它。它在尖叫。我尽量不去伤害它。我对这东西很紧张。它可能会咬我。我真的不想伤害它。它只是一只动物。
So I'm moving it along, and everything's going very well. And then with about eight inches to go, I took one more swipe, and the thing just bolted out from underneath the couch. It was lined with tassels. I couldn't really see under the couch. It bolted out from underneath the couch and ran directly into the fireplace, which is about three feet away. The fireplace was directly ahead of it, and it ran into the fire and caught on fire, and ran directly back out and directly back under the couch.
所以我把它往前推，一切都进展得非常好。然后还剩大约八英寸时，我又扫了一下，那东西直接从沙发底下窜了出来。它边缘装饰着流苏。我没法真正看清沙发下面。它从沙发底下窜出来，直接跑进了大约三英尺外的壁炉。壁炉就在它正前方，它跑进火里，身上着了火，直接跑了出来，又直接跑回沙发底下。
Is it on fire?
它着火了吗？
It was on fire. Yeah, the tail, the bushy fur, the whole bit. I mean, it wasn't, like, flaming or anything. But it was smoking. And there was a little bit of fire coming off the tail. So it runs back under the couch. And the couch catches on fire in seconds-- I mean, in seconds. It must have had dust under there or something else. But it just caught on fire immediately.
它着火了。是的，尾巴，毛茸茸的毛，全身上下。我的意思是，它没有，像，冒火光或者什么的。但它在冒烟。它的尾巴上冒出了一点火。所以它跑回沙发底下。沙发几秒钟内就着火了——我的意思是，几秒钟内。它下面一定有灰尘或其他东西。但它立即着火了。
And my partner and I just don't even talk. We just grab the couch, heave it upside down. And now there's plenty of oxygen for the fire to really get going. And it starts up. And we're patting it out. And it's sort of getting away from us.
我和我搭档甚至没交谈。我们只是抓住沙发，把它翻过来。现在火有充足的氧气可以真正烧起来了。它烧起来了。我们在拍打它。它有点失控了。
So we grab the only thing that's really available. And those are these really nice silk pillows. And we have one in each hand, the both of us. And we're just windmilling away at this fire on the couch. And we put it out. But it's smoking terribly. And it was a disaster.
所以我们抓住了真正可用的唯一东西。那就是那些真的很漂亮的丝绸枕头。我们每个人每只手拿一个。我们只是在风车般地扑打沙发上的火。我们把它扑灭了。但它冒出的烟太可怕了。那是一场灾难。
The couch is upside down. The bottom of it is burnt. The house is filling with smoke from the couch. The squirrel, when it went under the couch, in its death throes, just latched onto the bottom of the couch. It's like this smoking piece of gristle underneath the couch, latched on there with its claws. And we're pounding, smearing it all over the place. The smoke alarms are firing away. The guy's standing with handkerchiefs and paper towels up around his nose, which is still bleeding. His pajamas are a mess. They're covered with blood, the front of them.
沙发底朝天。底部烧焦了。房子里满是从沙发冒出的烟。松鼠，当它跑到沙发下时，在临死挣扎中，抓住了沙发底部。它像一块烧焦的软骨在沙发下面，用爪子抓在上面。我们正在捶打，把它抹得到处都是。烟雾报警器响个不停。那家伙站在那里，用手帕和纸巾捂着鼻子，鼻子还在流血。他的睡衣一团糟。它们覆盖着血，前面都是。
And we finally get the fire out. And we're both completely red, sweating, because we're dressed for, like, zero degree weather. And it's hot there by the fire. We're mortified. The house is full of smoke.
我们终于把火扑灭了。我们都全身通红，出汗，因为我们穿着像是零度天气穿的衣服。火旁边很热。我们尴尬极了。房子里满是烟。
The wife just looks around and just starts to cry. She goes, what have you done? What have you done to my house? You could see her just clicking things off on her fingers. OK, the dead squirrel, ruined pillows, need a new couch, the walls are covered with soot, the fire alarms are going off, my husband's disfigured. And then she really kind of just lost it.
妻子只是环顾四周，开始哭。她说，你们做了什么？你们对我的房子做了什么？你可以看到她只是在手指上数着事情。好吧，死松鼠，毁了的枕头，需要一张新沙发，墙壁覆盖着煤烟，火灾警报响个不停，我丈夫毁容了。然后她真的有点崩溃了。
And he was just looking at us and shaking his head, like he couldn't believe that these two idiots showed up and did this to his house over nothing, really. And he just goes, you know, you really haven't done anything wrong. I can't point to any one thing that you did that I have a reason to get angry about. You really haven't done anything wrong. I mean, we did call you. But I just, I can't thank you for this. They call for a squirrel. They end up with $3,000, $4,000 worth of damage and a broken nose. And this is all within about five minutes.
而他只是看着我们摇头，好像不敢相信这两个白痴出现，为了没什么事就这样对待他的房子。他只是说，你知道，你们真的没做错什么。我无法指出你们做的任何一件事我有理由生气。你们真的没做错什么。我的意思是，我们确实叫了你们。但我只是，我不能为此感谢你们。他们因为松鼠叫人。他们最终得到了价值3000、4000美元的损失和一个断掉的鼻子。这都在大约五分钟内。
Could that have happened to you now, 13 years later?
13年后的今天，那还会发生在你身上吗？
There's always a new mistake to be made. I don't think I would make that particular mistake. I mean, you make plenty of mistakes. You make plenty of mistakes. That's just part of that job. You just try not to make the same one twice. But there's such variety that you're going to make hundreds, you're going to make thousands of mistakes, until you really get a handle on what you're doing.
总会有新的错误可以犯。我不认为我会犯那个特定的错误。我的意思是，你犯很多错误。你犯很多错误。那只是那份工作的一部分。你只是尽量不要犯同一个错误两次。但种类繁多，你会犯数百，你会犯数千个错误，直到你真正掌握你在做什么。
And with police work, they afford you plenty of space to make mistakes. But there's things that just aren't your responsibility. If you get involved in things that aren't your responsibility, or that you're really not equipped to handle, or that don't have a specific plan, a plan that's thought through to a conclusion, you probably should reevaluate what you're doing.
对于警察工作，他们给了你足够的空间去犯错。但有些事情不是你的责任。如果你卷入了不是你的责任的事情，或者你根本没有能力处理的事情，或者没有具体计划，没有想清楚结果的计划，你可能应该重新评估你在做什么。
Yeah, now that you mention that, that's right. You walk into the house, thinking OK, we'll get this squirrel. Like, how were you going to get the squirrel? What was the best case scenario?
是的，既然你提到了，那是对的。你走进房子，想着好吧，我们要抓住这只松鼠。就像，你打算怎么抓这只松鼠？最好的情况是什么？
That's a great question. I guess I was thinking that I would go up there in the attic and find this cowering squirrel and somehow kind of lure it into some kind of a trap. And then walk out with it and be like a hero. But as it turned out, it was a Pyrrhic victory for the squirrel, but the squirrel definitely won. The squirrel really kicked our ass.
这是个好问题。我猜我在想我会上阁楼找到这只畏缩的松鼠，不知何故把它引诱进某种陷阱。然后带着它走出来，像个英雄。但事实证明，这对松鼠来说是一场惨胜，但松鼠肯定赢了。松鼠真的踢了我们的屁股。
That is not what you want to be saying at the end of the day.
那不是你想在一天结束时说的话。
No. No. I mean, it took a long time to even tell people about it. I was so new. I didn't want to know what a bonehead I was when I first came onto the job.
不。不。我的意思是，我花了好长时间才告诉别人。我当时太新了。我不想知道我刚开始工作时是多么笨。
Our interviewee, who asked not to be named on the radio, has been on the force for 28 years.
我们的受访者，要求不在广播中提及名字，已经在警队工作了28年。
[MUSIC - "FOX SQUIRREL" BY MUDDY WATERS]
[音乐 - 泥水佬演唱的“狐狸松鼠”]
Act Four, Fiascoes as a Force for Good. George Clooney, Barbara Streisand, Jennifer Aniston, Vidal Sassoon, Jodie Foster, Alicia Silverstone, Brad Pitt, Keanu Reeves, Sharon Stone, and John Travolta, also George Burns, Bob Hope, Gene Kelly, Gena Rowlands, also Quentin Tarantino, John Waters, Nora Ephron-- Margy Rochlin has interviewed all these people.
第四幕，惨败作为一种向善力量。乔治·克鲁尼、芭芭拉·史翠珊、詹妮弗·安妮斯顿、维达·沙宣、朱迪·福斯特、艾丽西亚·希尔弗斯通、布拉德·皮特、基努·里维斯、莎朗·斯通和约翰·特拉沃尔塔，还有乔治·伯恩斯、鲍勃·霍普、吉恩·凯利、吉娜·罗兰兹，还有昆汀·塔伦蒂诺、约翰·沃特斯、诺拉·艾芙隆——玛吉·罗克林采访了所有这些人。
She does big magazine feature stories for big magazines in the New York Times. But the very, very first big feature assignment she was actually sent out on was by a publication in 1982. The Los Angeles Reader sent out a very nervous, very youthful Margy Rochlin to interview Moon Unit Zappa. You may remember her, daughter of Frank Zappa.
她为《纽约时报》的大型杂志撰写大型专题报道。但她实际上被派出的第一个非常、非常大的专题任务是在1982年。洛杉矶读者报派出了一个非常紧张、非常年轻的玛吉·罗克林去采访月球单元·扎帕（Moon Unit Zappa）。你可能记得她，弗兰克·扎帕的女儿。
She had consented to her second interview ever after the release of her runaway hit song, "Valley Girl."
她在她的热门歌曲“山谷女孩”发布后，同意接受她有史以来第二次采访。
In this little bit that she does on this song, she's using a lot of this language, this sort of Valspeak that no one had ever heard before. And it was considered really exotic. And so I was from the valley, so I was sent to go talk to her.
她在她这首歌做的这一点里，她使用了大量的语言，这种以前从未有人听说过的山谷语言。这被认为真的很异国情调。所以我是来自山谷的，所以我被派去和她谈话。
She was one of your people. Speak to her in your secret, private argot.
她是你的族人。用你的秘密、私人行话和她交谈。
Exactly. And of course, what is so touching to me is that I totally bought that. You're right. I'm the right person for the job. I'm going to go speak to her in the valley language. And we will bond.
没错。当然，让我感到感动的是我完全买账了。你是对的。我是这份工作的合适人选。我要去用山谷语言和她交谈。我们会结缘。
So you get there, and you're a bit nervous. And the pressure is on. Which is, of course, the setting for a possible triumph or possible fiasco. And what happens next?
所以你到了那里，你有点紧张。压力很大。这当然是可能的胜利或可能的惨败的场景。接下来发生了什么？
Well, what I noticed was it was a tense situation. I just didn't feel like it was going very well. And the mother was sort of hovering.
嗯，我注意到情况很紧张。我只是觉得进展不顺。母亲在徘徊。
Right. Well, we have a recording of it, because you had a tape recorder rolling during this.
对。嗯，我们有一份录音，因为你当时带着录音机。
Yes.
是的。
What are some other hang outs in the valley, besides the Galleria?
除了购物中心，山谷里还有哪些常去的地方？
Bowling alleys with big arcades are very popular.
带有大型游戏厅的保龄球馆非常受欢迎。
Like what?
像什么？
Oh, I'm trying-- at this point, I'm sort of that rock bottom level that everyone can get at in an interview, where you're just saying, like, what's your favorite color? And she's trying to help me along.
哦，我在尝试——在这一点上，我处于每个人在采访中都能达到的那种底层水平，你只是在说，你的最爱颜色是什么？她在试图帮我。
Kirkwood's is gone.
柯克伍德（Kirkwood's）没了。
It's now the sports center.
它现在是体育中心。
Oh, but it's the same thing?
哦，但它是一样的东西吗？
Yeah, it's still very popular.
是的，它仍然很受欢迎。
So we're seated in the den. And the mother made me coffee. But I was too nervous to drink it. But I sort of kept staring at it. And she kept staring at it. And I felt like it was pretty important that at some point, I better drain that coffee cup.
所以我们坐在书房里。母亲为我做了咖啡。但我太紧张了，没喝。但我只是盯着它看。她也一直盯着它看。我觉得在某个时候，最好还是把那杯咖啡喝掉，这相当重要。
And so what happened was Moon told me a joke. And I didn't see the joke coming. And right before she told me the joke, I had taken a big swig of the coffee, which was now cold. And when she told me the joke, I burst out laughing. And I started to choke. And so I pressed my lips together, so I didn't spit it out. I didn't want to do a spit-take. And the coffee came shooting out my nose.
所以发生的事情是月球单元告诉了我一个笑话。我没预见到那个笑话。在她说笑话之前，我喝了一大口已经冷了的咖啡。当她说笑话时，我忍不住笑出来。我开始呛到。所以我紧闭嘴唇，这样我就没吐出来。我不想吐出来。咖啡从我的鼻子里喷出来了。
Shooting out your nose?
从你的鼻子里喷出来？
Shooting right out my nose.
直接从我的鼻子里喷出来。
Are you OK?
你没事吧？
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
Are you OK? Get your hands up.
你没事吧？把手举起来。
I was really embarrassed, but simultaneously, I couldn't breath. At the same time, I was choking. And I jumped up. And I sort of started running around the room, knocking things over. And I think that they didn't know what was going on. But the mother began chasing me.
我真的很尴尬，但同时，我无法呼吸。同时，我正在呛到。我跳了起来。我开始在房间里乱跑，撞倒东西。我想他们不知道发生了什么。但母亲开始追我。
She began chasing you?
她开始追你？
She began chasing me, because I was running from corner to corner, trying to catch my breath. And she began chasing me. And at a certain point, she got behind me, and she gave me the Heimlich maneuver.
她开始追我，因为我正从一个角落跑到另一个角落，试图喘口气。她开始追我。在某一点，她到了我身后，她给了我海姆利克急救法。
Put your arms up. No, really. Seriously? OK?
把胳膊举起来。不，真的。认真的？好的？
Let's do the Heimlich maneuver.
让我们做海姆利克急救法。
Well, I've been in the news business-- I've been a reporter for 20 years. And nobody's ever given me the Heimlich maneuver while I've been on a story.
嗯，我一直在新闻行业——我当记者20年了。当我在报道故事时，从没有人给我做过海姆利克急救法。
Well, I always say that it's a benchmark. It's a very low benchmark. And I can do any interview. I can get thrown off a set. I can be cursed out by the subject, but I can leave and get in the car, and I can drive home and think, I didn't blow coffee out my nose.
嗯，我总是说这是一种基准。这是一个非常低的基准。我可以做任何采访。我可以被从片场赶出来。我可以被采访对象诅咒，但我可以离开，坐进车里，开车回家想，我没有把咖啡喷出鼻子。
Now, what happened after that?
现在，那之后发生了什么？
It was sort of like we'd all been in an earthquake together. And all of nervousness left the room. And suddenly we were three gals, just chatting. And I remember that I sort of hugged them both when I left.
那就像我们都在地震中一起待过一样。房间里所有的紧张感都消失了。突然我们成了三个姑娘，只是聊天。我记得我离开时拥抱了她们俩。
Wow.
哇。
They were now my friends.
她们现在是我的朋友了。
It's interesting, because one of our criteria for a fiasco is that all social order, the normal social structure breaks down. And literally, that's what happens here. The normal interview stops. And the social structure of the moment completely changes. The mom gives you the Heimlich maneuver. And then, suddenly, it stops feeling like an interview.
这很有趣，因为惨败的标准之一是所有社会秩序，正常的社会结构崩溃了。事实上，这就是这里发生的事情。正常的采访停止了。那一刻的社会结构彻底改变了。妈妈给了你海姆利克急救法。然后，突然间，它感觉不再像一次采访了。
Yeah. And I have to say that it was a very embarrassing experience, and it completely made me feel close to them. It was so interesting. When Moon's father died a while ago, I bumped into her somewhere, and we both burst into tears. I really felt like a little sister of mine had had a loss. The starting point was--
是的。我不得不说那是一次非常尴尬的经历，它完全让我感到和她们亲近。这太有趣了。当月球单元的父亲前段时间去世时，我在某个地方碰到了她，我们俩都泪流满面。我真的觉得我的一个小妹妹遭受了损失。起点是——
That moment.
那个时刻。
--that moment.
——那个时刻。
To me, the thing about it that's useful is that it shows the useful purpose of a fiasco. That is, when social order breaks down, that could be a force not just for chaos and for entropy and for evil, but in fact, that could be a force for good.
对我来说，关于它有用的地方是，它显示了惨败的有用目的。也就是说，当社会秩序崩溃时，那可能不仅仅是混乱、熵和邪恶的力量，事实上，那可能是一种向善的力量。
Right.
对。
It can bring people together.
它可以把人们聚在一起。
Right. It was actually this huge success to me. I'd never been sent out under these kind of circumstances before. And I remember we beat the local paper. The Herald Examiner followed us a week later. And so we had the first story. And it was sort of considered the definitive one, because we had this glossary of terms that I had made or put together.
对。这对我来说实际上是一个巨大的成功。在此之前我从未在这种情况下被派出去。我记得我们打败了当地报纸。先驱审查员一周后跟进了我们。所以我们有了第一个故事。它被认为是决定性的那一个，因为我们有这个词汇表，我制作或整理在一起。
Of Valleyspeak terms.
关于山谷用语的术语。
Of Valleyspeak terms. And then it was syndicated.
关于山谷用语的术语。然后它被辛迪加化了。
And most of the quotable stuff that you ended up using in your story happened after the incident?
而你最终在故事中使用的引用内容大部分都发生在事故之后？
Yeah.
是的。
It happened after squirting the coffee through your nose.
发生在把咖啡从你的鼻子喷出来之后。
Right, exactly. Exactly. It's a technique I don't suggest anyone trying. For years afterwards, Moon would send me postcards. And on the postcard somewhere would be a picture of a nose, and there would be liquid coming out of it. Sort of like my logo.
对，没错。没错。这是一个我不建议任何人尝试的技术。在那之后很多年，月球单元会给我寄明信片。明信片上的某个地方会有一张鼻子的照片，会有液体从里面出来。有点像我的标志。
Margy Rochlin in Los Angeles.
玛吉·罗克林，在洛杉矶。
[MUSIC - "DAMAGE CONTROL" BY THE IDLE HANDS] [MUSIC - "DAMAGE CONTROL" BY THE IDLE HANDS]
[音乐 - “损害控制” - 空闲之手乐队] [音乐 - “损害控制” - 空闲之手乐队]
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Paul Tough, Alix Siegel, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors for today's program, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help today from Dana Chivvis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Musical help today from John Connors and Damien Graef.
嗯，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普戴克和我自己制作，保罗·塔夫、阿利克斯·西格尔和朱莉·斯奈德共同制作。今天节目的特约编辑，杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。Dana Chivvis提供了制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。伊莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨运营我们的网站。John Connors和Damien Graef提供了今天的音乐帮助。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia, who walks into our studio at the end of each and every episode of our show to grimly assess the damage.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚，他在我们每一集节目的最后走进我们的录音室，冷酷地评估损失。
Dead squirrel, ruined pillows, need a new couch. The walls are covered with soot. The fire alarms are going off.
死松鼠，毁了的枕头，需要一张新沙发。墙壁覆盖着煤烟。火灾警报响个不停。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多关于美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。